[Music]
to bring us the results of the balloting
for Best Foreign Language Film
here are two gentlemen who are
well-versed both in the arts and
diplomacy the United States Ambassador
to Mexico and the president of the
Motion Picture Association of America
mr. John Gavin and mr. Jack Valenti
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
before we present this award we have an
honored guest in the audience tonight
that we would like to introduce to you
Jack would you do the honors
but you please welcome is just one
Antonio Samaranch the wife of the
president of the International Olympic
Committee
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Bahadur ambassador shall we begin
whenever a film comes from wherever it
comes from and by whatever route it
reaches a screen in this country the
creativity expressed bias makers is very
welcome indeed and never has that been
more true than of the five nominees this
year from five different countries and
five different cultures they are Spain
Carmen story of passion from France
entre news a film about intimate
relationships and from Sweden Fanny and
Alexander story of the complications of
family life
[Applause]
[Music]
from Hungary Jobs rivalled story of
survival in wartime Europe
[Applause]
as from Algeria the power of film
allegory of history set to - and the
winner is winner is Sweden for Fanny and
Alexander writer director Ingmar Bergman
is directing the play
accepting for him is the producer of
Patty and Alexandra beyond honor and
with him mrs. Ingmar Bergman
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen thanks the members
of the Academy for having a very good
taste I think so
secondly I have in my pocket
a book with 265 names which I'm going to
read to you all the people I want to
thank but I will spare you that tonight
the SS when I twist my thoughts go to
Ingmar in Munich but also really to the
250 or 500 people who have contributed
to the success the effort by making
Fanny and Alexander work as the crowning
achievement of Ingmar Bergman's career
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
I just am going to hurry to Ingmar and
tell him about the warm and wonderful
reception he you have given his film
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
I want to thank John Gavin and Jack
Valenti they're the two most exciting
guys who have been out here since
Johnson and Kaplan The Price Waterhouse
you
[Applause]